im studio begrüße ich professor
cronenberg politikwissenschaftler und
rudolf dreßler
sie waren auch noch stellvertretender
vorsitzender der bundestagsfraktion sind
sozialpolitiker satz soziale herz der
spd frauen 20 jahre lang im bundestag
wie haben sie denn die nachricht heute
aufgefasst dass andrea nahles das
handtuch schmeißt also ich habe das so
aufgefasst dass sie für sich selbst
keinen ausweg mehr sah und ich habe
gestern noch geglaubt dass das eine
flucht nach vorne ist ihre kandidatur
weil wenn sie drei monate ins land
ziehen lässt dann haben sich ihre gegner
zusammengefunden und die abwahl ist
wahrscheinlicher aber selbst diese
aussicht mit der flucht nach vorne
könnte sie sich noch einmal retten hat
sie sich verschätzt und das ist jetzt
was sie gemacht hat das einzig richtige
sonst wäre es für sie ganz schlimm
gewesen wenn sind geblieben wäre
demütigende demütigend und für die spd
wäre es auch nicht besonders drollig
gewesen wenn ihre fraktionsvorsitzende
ohne gegenkandidatur abgewählt worden
wäre
und vor diesem dilemma hat sie die spd
auch bewahrt insoweit muss man ihr sogar
noch dankbar sein wie abgewählt also wie
geht das also wenn es doch nur sie gibt
als einzige kandidatin wenn sie nicht
mehr als die hälfte der stimmen bekommt
dann gilt sie im ersten wahlgang als
abgewählt also jedenfalls nicht das
quorum erreicht und damit abgewählt wenn
sie dann in den zweiten wahlgang ginge
dann wäre das der zweite schritt zum
selbstmord es wird sie nicht gemacht
dass er hätte sie nicht gemacht ist
meine feste überzeugung
herr professor das wäre das völlige
debakel gewesen bei einer kandidatin
wiederwahl keine ausreichende mehrheit
ohne gegenkandidat das wäre der
offenbarungseid schlechthin gewesen und
ganz offenbar ist es ja so gewesen dass
sie in den letzten tagen
hinweise bekommen hat dass sie genau
darauf zusteuert insofern hat sie jetzt
hier die reißleine gezogen und sich
selbst und der fraktion und der partei
dieses debakel erspart so weit so gut
aber eben auch so schlecht denn jetzt
ist ja die frage die im raum steht wer
soll es denn besser machen denn es geht
ja um besser nicht nur anders sondern
besser und ganz offenbar ist es ja so
dass man jetzt übergangsweise sucht und
das ist ja schon auch ausdruck erster
man will nichts überstürzen aber
zweitens und das ist entscheidend es
drängt sich ja gar niemand auf denn die
aufgaben vor denen man steht die sind
natürlich riesengroß vielleicht auch gar
nicht mehr zu bewältigen bevor wir die
zukunft gucken möchte ich nochmal
interesse auf den zustand der spd heute
schauen
es gab so viele gegenstimmen so viele
giftpfeile hieß es auch gegen andrea
nahles in welchem zustand ist da die spd
muss die nicht auch sag's mal andersrum
auch bei einem schwierigen fahrwasser
wenn man wahlen verliert wie bei der
europawahl trotzdem dann auch zur
vorsitzenden stehen ja dass man sich
dabei also das ist eine frage der
einschätzung wenn ich bei einem
wahlergebnis von 15,8 prozent nicht
einmal den vorsitz in zweifel ziehen
kann mich sozusagen in einem strohhalm
festzuhalten gedenkt der gar keiner mehr
ist das thema volkspartei würde ich in
diesem zusammenhang nicht mehr wagen in
den mund zu nehmen kann man auch nicht
kann man auch ernsthaft nicht
und das bedeutet sie hat andrea nahles
hat durch diesen rücktritt und die
formulierungen die sie gewählt hat ja
selbst im nachhinein noch kundgetan dass
sie die spd wie sie sich jetzt darstellt
und wie sie sie mit ihr gemacht hat
nichts mehr im stande war einzuordnen
denn wenn sie sagt sie hätte in den
letzten tagen oder im letzten tag
erkannt dass sie keine mehrheit hat
heißt das im analogie schluss dass sie
sich vor einem tag noch nicht klar darum
war wie ihre eigene partei zu ihr steht
das ist nicht besonders tragfähig aber
die spd stellt doch immer die
solidarität ganz vorne hin schreibt sich
das auf die fahne und es ist doch im
prinzip ein programmatisches problem was
die spd hat vor dem hintergrund auch der
umwälzung kraft wenn man sieht dass
junge wähler massenweise zu den grünen
überlassen da gibt es noch ein problem
der programmatik und nicht unbedingt des
personals also die frage ist doch
inwieweit jetzt dieser personalwechsel
tatsächlich die spd aus der krise holen
kann also mit verlaub der
personalwechsel ist verursacht wurden
von von nahles silber sie hat noch vor
drei tagen erklärt man wolle nicht in
eine personaldebatte
man wolle sich in der sache orientieren
an der sache orientieren und genau einen
tag nachdem sie sich an der sache
orientieren wollte hat sie im alleingang
sich selbst zur disposition gestellt das
bedeutet dass irgendwann die solidarität
mit einem solchen kollektiv wie
bundestagsfraktion oder auch
sozialdemokratische partei zu ende
gegangen ist wie lange sind sie denn
schon enttäuscht von der vorsitzenden
alles also ich bin enttäuscht seitdem
sie dieses amt als arbeitsministerin
übernommen hat weil die ein
arbeitsergebnisse die sie als
arbeitsministerin vorgelegt hat nach
meiner meinung sozialdemokratischen
inhalten jedenfalls in großen teilen
entschieden widersprechen
aber die spd hat doch in dieser großen
koalition auch viel erreicht es ist halt
noch nicht vermittelt worden also mit
verlaub das haben journalisten
geschrieben und die dass sie viel
erreicht habe und diejenigen die es
gemacht haben in der großen koalition
haben es freudvoll entgegengenommen und
haben es nach gebetet wenn sie mir
erklären wollen dass die finanzierung
der mitte rente eine sozialleistung des
staates an mütter die mit rente nichts
zu tun haben mit beitragszahlungen auch
nicht aus den beitragsgeldern finanziert
wenn wenn das noch solidarität
provozieren soll dann habe ich politik
in meinem leben jedenfalls
offensichtlich falsch wenn der professor
können sie den ärger von
dressler verstehen mag wird sie ein
billiges rudolf dreßler ärgert sich ja
nicht erst jetzt seit jüngstem sondern
schon seit langer zeit was natürlich
hier auch deutlich wird ist im grunde
ein tiefer graben in der partei wir
haben heute schon darüber gesprochen
denn nicht zuletzt hat es gibt auch
andere gründe aber nicht zuletzt
natürlich mit der agenda-politik den
hartz-reformen sogenannten hartz
reformen und andere mehr zusammenhängt
ich würde zur erde musste dass ihr
geradezu ja ich das bräuchte ich gerade
sagen zur ehrenrettung von frau nahles
ist es ja so sie wie das ja ich möchte
sie hat das gesehen
sie hat sich bemüht sage ich als
unabhängiger beobachter eben hier
highland zu wirken sie wollte das
überwinden
da hat sie debatten angestoßen sie
wollte integrieren
sie wollte da einen soweit das möglich
ist aber wir haben nach wie vor einer
der nahles rücktritt überhaupt nichts
wir haben sozusagen so ein scholz
strömung diesen pragmatischen seeheimer
netzwerker diese richtung die wollen
regieren die sagen so sozial liberal
mitte das ist der kurs dann gibt es
einen anderen kurs bis hin zu kühnheit
ich über spitze hilde mattheis andere
die sagen nie wir haben das
sozialdemokratische tafelsilber
verscherbelt ich würde an einer stelle
dressler ihm da widersprechen wollen
natürlich mütter rente kann mir nicht
von der spd kam von der csu
aber wenn man sich diesen
koalitionsvertrag anschaut gibt es
glaube ich eine ganze reihe von punkten
die die die sozialdemokratische
handschrift ja tragen und trotzdem ist
die spd da wo sie ist und trotzdem ist
alles gescheitert ich will sagen
damit ist jetzt überhaupt nicht geholfen
des finales zurückgetreten ist es drängt
sich kein anderer auf und letztendlich
muss die partei klären wohin will sie
was will sie programmatisch inhaltlich
klima wäre ich sehr skeptisch dass das
das gewinnerthema gerade der spd ist das
ist es bestimmt nicht wohin will sie
inhaltlich welchen aufbruch welche
zukunftsidee europawahlkampf völlig
völlig schuldig geblieben was will die
spd großartig in europa machen das ist
das erste kapitel des koalitionsvertrags
gewesen jetzt weiß der schultes wieder
besser
aber ich will nur sagen auch natürlich
die innerparteiliche kritik und diese
debatten wo will man hin und nicht
zuletzt mit wem will man denn eine
machtbasis schaffen wohin will man das
land führen mitte mitte links links das
sind sicherlich fragen müssen geklärt
werden das braucht sehr viel zeit für
diese kunden möchten sie haben soeben
ein anderer stelle eine ganz wichtige
bemerkung gemacht die lautete frau
nahles hat sich bemüht das wenn ich sie
daran erinnern darf wenn ich das in ein
zeugnis schreiben heißt das übersetzt
der mann hat den anforderungen nicht
genügt ja oder die frau
da widerspreche ich ihn nicht nur die
frage ist doch glaube ich und ich glaube
dass stimmen sie mehr zur treffler wer
kann es denn jetzt besser machen wer
drängen sich denn jetzt auch sie hat es
bemüht sie war damit nicht erfolgreich
denn das ist doch völlig klar guckt man
sich die wahlergebnisse an guckt man
sich den zustand an das jetzt sigmar
gabriel sagt die partei muss entgiftet
werden ich meine das sind ja selbst
alles auch protagonisten in einer
debattenkultur die man so ja gar nicht
mehr nennen bezeichnen kann also die spd
ist tatsächlich in einem dramatischen
zustand